what's up guys Samuel Leeds here and you
may have watched last year 12 months ago
I did a video and I've never known
anyone do a video like this it was one
of my most popular YouTube videos where
I exposed I revealed my 2018 property
investing business plan and I've told
everybody exactly what where when how
much I was going to be buying my own
properties avoiding my own personal
portfolio so I thought it'd be really
cool to do a part two to that video and
on this video I'm gonna tell you exactly
what I did by over 2018 and potentially
if you guys want it I can even do
another video where I'm gonna talk about
exactly what I'm gonna buy in 2019 I am
going to buy 10 houses in total two of
those houses are going to be lease
option agreement that I'll be keeping
for myself
so I told you that I was gonna buy to
lease option agreement deals no money
down which I did I achieved that I
didn't achieve everything on the video I
did get to lease option agreement I've
got many more in the back many more
pending I also did find other deals with
my students that they bought but I
personally got to lease option agreement
deals so the first one was no money down
and it was in Bradford and it was if the
guy was so motivated to sell you have no
equity on the property at all and I said
that I would buy it off him for I think
he was eighty five thousand pound in
five years it's currently worth about 77
and I'm renting out for 450 pounds I'm
paying him one hundred and fifty pound
or they're in there bounce so I'm making
a little bit of cash flow each month
I've got the option to buy it in the
next five years for 85 so I'm reasonably
happy with that but it's not the most
exciting deal in the world the second
one I bought which was a lease option
agreement was a little bit more
interesting and that was in Litchfield
which is in the Midlands a very nice
city in the Midlands it's a HMO so this
was a guy who inherited no not inherited
he II he split up from his wife and his
wife and him had a big property
portfolio together more led by her and
then when they split up they split the
properties up and he didn't really want
to deal with them he was like oh I don't
want these houses so I bought one of his
HMOs in Litchfield off him five bed hate
you know it was all rented out for two
thousand five hundred pounds a month so
reasonably decent rents it was a fine
HMO but one of the tenants was very very
bad
was smoking weeds and he was like ah so
I just said to him look how much do you
want - he wanted to sell the property
how much do you want to buy it sell it
for he said I want to sell it to 350,000
pounds so I said to him either I'll give
you the money now the put the payment
how much I give you will be on my terms
so I'll give you two hundred and seventy
five thousand pounds now and he was like
oh no that's really no I said oh I'll
give you what you want the full asking
price but I'll pay you on my terms which
is I'll give you five hundred pounds a
month which will contribute towards the
the purchase price and then in three
years time I'll give you the three
hundred and fifty thousand pounds - the
five hundred pounds that I've obtained
here and he was like all right so we did
a deal so I'm now paying him five
hundred pounds a month but that's going
towards the purchase price I sorted out
the tenant situation I'm renting out for
two and a half thousand pound months I'm
making really good profit on that every
single month and I put down like nothing
like 750 pounds for the semester fee so
I was really really happy with that deal
so those were my two juicy lease option
agreements in 2018 I'm going to be
straightforward
buy low rent hi HMOs properties three
and four I said I was gonna buy two HMOs
and I said I was gonna buy them in
Middlesbrough so how did that go well
not amazingly well just didn't quite go
to plan I bought one HMO in
Middlesbrough and it was in it was just
off present Road so I'll tell exactly
what was just off present roads
ten minute walk from the city centre and
I bought it really cheap I bought it for
fifty two thousand pounds and I just
thought let's see what happens bought it
for 50 - well I can rent those four
rooms and get three bedrooms to
reception rooms I spent about five
thousand pounds on a light refurb how
did that go okay okay
rent it out three of the rooms for 325
pounds the fourth room just stuck I know
other people as well that were invested
in that area and some people really
liked it some people think it's a bit
saturated I was going to invest in
Middlesbrough again I think I'd go just
that little bit closer to the center
HMOs in some of the northern areas the
returns on investment is just incredible
but there have been a lot of people
probably since I
revealed my business plan and wrote my
book buy low rent hi there's a lot of
southern investors buying cake demos and
some of the cheaper northern cities the
area I was in probably slightly
saturated so I decided not to buy my
second HMO Middlesboro his plans I went
and bought two more HMOs and I bought
them in the Midlands in Walsall although
in Warsaw I paid more for them I paid
more like 150 the return on investment
because they're always full and the
rents were a little bit higher the
return on investment is actually
probably about the same it's not better
so they almost 3 h mo properties one in
Middlesbrough in Warsaw they're giving
me around about 20 to 25 percent return
on investment I'm not gonna be
refinancing though I'm just going to
leave my money in and I'm reasonably
happy with those what can I say I do
love Middlesbrough
my plan is to buy a cheap HMO property
it won't be a current HMO it would just
be a big derelict property and to can't
buy it for cash I'll then spend six
months doing it up renovating it into a
nice big professional house of multiple
occupancy after six months I will then
refinance the property and I will pull
out all of the money that I put in and
potentially even some of the refurb
costs as well meaning it will be left
with a very little money down deal and
of course I'll be then generating a high
rental income from it as well so the
sixth property that I bought this was
the buy refurbish refinance strategy a
strategy that I'm very excited about at
the moment when I first started out in
property it was a case of ice to buy
them below market value and then I would
refinance them the same day they changed
the rules back in about 2008 2009 and
said you have to wait six months to
refinance properties and everyone was
like all the days of property investing
her over and the credit crunch came and
everything which I thought was a new
cereal about six months ago now they
changed the rules again and Kent
Reliant's said that you can refinance
now straight away so they abolished the
six month rule so I thought well hey
let's really get back into this strategy
so bought property this was in stafford
a big house
it was very rundown I bought it for 150
mm I think it was or maybe you
150 to 500 did a big reverb on it and
then turned it into a commercial HMO the
evaluation that came back it wasn't it
was very messy it was a little bit
harder than all but I did manage to pull
out most of my money and just left in
about 15,000 pounds so because you know
I just left 15,000 pounds in it it's not
bad considering or making a thousand
pounds per month profit from the deal so
the return on investment in that is like
90 percent return on investment and that
was using rebuy refurbish refinance
strategy which overall very pleased with
title splitting this is pretty fun they
call this slice and dice and it's where
you buy a big property maybe an old
house and you convert it into two
apartments and minimum of two apartments
and you split the title and then sell
each apartment leaving you with a nice
profit property number seven and this
was title splitting again this is
something that I'm very excited about
I've got multiple properties like this
going through at the moment but the one
that was successful was just a a
property that I bought reasonably big
house I split it into four apartments
and got Planning Commission granted
which was which was really fantastic if
you're going to buy a property and
you're relying on having to get Planning
Commission my advice would be buy it's
subject to planning permission so that's
what I did which worked really well so
yeah we turned into four apartments I
could prop the values gone right up I
could probably refinance it but I'm not
gonna because I'm renting the apartments
out for a very very healthy amount to my
return investment on that is around
about 32% again that was in the Midlands
I mean I'm listing quite a lot in the
Midlands this year really happy with
that definitely meeting a lot more title
splitting it's quite satisfying turning
a property into multiple units and
you're also providing more accommodation
to the country which i think is a really
good thing to seaside apartments so
under you buying a seaside apartment
hopefully for around about 85,000 pounds
renting it out to 750 pounds and it is
gonna be in weston-super-mare property
eight you've probably seen on the video
my prediction was I said that there was
a lot of apartments in c-town areas and
there was a lot of regeneration going
into certain sea town areas which was
shooting the prices right up and I've
told you
explains why in the video a year ago
there was going to be buying a an
apartment in weston-super-mare which I
did and people didn't believe me but I
did do a video if you want if you want
to watch the video you can maybe just
search Samuel Leeds weston-super-mare I
managed to buy a property in
weston-super-mare see view property and
I paid a hundred and seventeen thousand
pound for it really got in with the
agent and I'm getting a lot of
properties now sent to me off market see
view for around about one hundred and
seventeen it's a little bit more than I
hope to tie I did say that I wanted to
pay a hundred thousand pounds max but I
am renting out the seven hundred pound a
month so buying a house for one hundred
and seventeen thousand renting out for
seven hundred pound a month return
investments pretty good and I've got a
very very good feeling about the capital
appreciation in weston-super-mare as
well so fingers crossed that will be a
very very worthwhile investment so my
strategy is going to be next year and I
have done this before but I may be doing
it again this coming year is going to be
to buy a property very very cheap maybe
around about sixty thousand pounds
hmm to renovate it cheaply perhaps
spending ten thousand pounds plus
furniture and then to sell it as an up
and running HMO to a wealthy busy
investor and make I want to make a
profit a gross profit of a minimum of
thirty thousand pounds doing that
property number nine so my prediction
was I told you I was gonna buy a
property and I was gonna turn it into a
hey chamo and then I was gonna sell it I
was gonna sell it maybe on a London
auction for someone that was purely
looking at it as a business anyway I
didn't end up doing that I think I
didn't do it because I just got so
carried away with some of the other
projects going on that didn't happen is
that good strategy possibly but I didn't
do that
sorry auction property auction property
is something that everybody thinks is a
great thing to do and lots of people
attempt however if you don't know what
you're doing you can fail miserably
property number ten was auction
properties did I buy any auction
properties yes I bought a freaking
castle from auction I bought that place
for eight hundred thousand pounds and we
are investing literally seven figures
into restoring it to its former glory
that actually we've got planning
permission already for twelve apartment
and three barns so that's 15 houses in
one and that is just ridiculously
exciting will it be profitable yes it
will but it's more than anything it's
just very satisfying seeing a castle
restored and we've also had a lot of
publicity from that we've got the the
Free French soldiers used to train there
Charles de Gaulle used to visit the
property who was the French leader
Winston Churchill's been there now it's
really beautiful because we've actually
become friends with the Free French and
we're talking about doing like a big
get-together there where we're inviting
the French over and there's just some
really classy beautiful things going on
with that building and I'm really really
honored to be able to buy it and restore
it if you want to see more about the
castle video just google Samuel leaves
his castle and you'll have a ton of
stuff on YouTube about that and that's
my definitely the project that I'm most
proud of in 2018 and I never expected it
it just kind of came out in the blue and
believe it or not it was on no money
down deal so people say you can't buy
houses with no money
I want a frigging castle we've no money
yes you can property number 25 and 26
was to Birmingham apartments which we
bought right in the set some Matt bang
in the city centre of Birmingham and we
bought them and we're gonna rent them
out or serviced accommodation we paid
120 for water for one of them which was
two bedrooms small and we paid a hundred
and thirty six thousand pounds for the
other one which is really lush and
they're gonna rent out as a single late
you'd probably read them out for about
750 to 850 pounds serviced accommodation
you rent them out for absolutely stupid
money they are renting out so well
they're going so well that I then
thought man
my apartments serviced accommodation
apartments are beautifully juicy how can
I be really smart and buy more without
buying them but benefit from the cash
flow so I ended up doing some rent to
serviced accommodation properties I did
a couple in Sheffield in Oxford joint
ventured on some deals as well like that
so rent to serviced accommodation is a
really good strategy that I'm excited
about - forget the rent - Service
accommodation deals just on their
Birmingham apartments that brings us to
27 27 houses this year plus some other
joint ventures and med service
accommodation so I think this year on 27
27 properties I think that's a big
achievement I've also been doing a lot
of training as well our property
training company has just
Bellona I think we're probably one of
the biggest certainly the
fastest-growing property investment
training companies in the UK which is
really exciting as well so really proud
of that team's growing companies grow in
2018 we've been a frigging fantastic
year for me both in terms of family
business and everything so you know what
I really do think that it's okay just
speak it out people are scared to speak
out what they're gonna do and get other
people copy them I'm happy to do that
because when you speak it out what
happens is you speak it into existence
and then it happens people say ah
believe it when I see it
but actually it's the other way around
actually you have to believe it first
and then you see it so a couple things
I'd like to say as I am this number one
I'd love to know what your property
investment business plan is going to be
over the next 12 months in 2019 so
comment below which strategies you're
most interested in rent to serviced
accommodation buying apartments title
splitting HMOs single let's buy - lets
refurbs development what do you want to
do number two if you want to see my
property investment business plan for
2019 it is juicy believe me we've got a
lot of big projects going on we're
negotiating some land deals some really
big development stuff it's juicy
if you want to know all the stats and
all the information exactly what I'm
planning on buying I'm happy to share
but I have to have enough people hitting
like on this video so if this video gets
a hundred likes I will then do a 2019
business plan as well god bless you
smash that like button I'll see you next
time